introduction guides and very well warm
welcome
to the participants uh
my name is adijah today i'll be talking
about
measuring micro particles with light and
machine learning
this talk is based on the
paper let me move yes
this paper which describes
a novel particle size analyzer
my personal contribution for this
project was through machine learning so
i'll explain
both uh we need a background information
first
so i'll explain what particles are where
they are used
i'll explain how they are measured uh
commercially
then i'll move on to explain the setup
described in the paper
uh what is novel about it and then how
machine learning can help for this
measurement
with this information then we can move
on to the machine learning model
development i'll explain
what were the inputs outputs
i'll describe the data set i'll show you
the results
after that i would like to discuss
certain details
about this machine learning pipeline and
i'll conclude my talk with
certain take-home messages um
related to a comparison between physics
driven models to data driven models
and a comparison between applied machine
learning to
machine machine learning research so
let's start
with particles what are particles um
we can find them in nature readily but
we can also produce them
they can be of many different materials
they can be spherical non-spherical
or even hello we can put uh things
inside
microparticles they are used in many
different industries
from cosmetics to pharmaceuticals um now
a natural question to ask
is okay but why do we care about
particle size
we care because it's an important
parameter
that affects the performance
of the product of the final product
so now let's discuss what is particle
size
so for spherical particles uh with just
one number
right the diameter we can describe the
whole particle
um but as you can imagine for a group of
particles
we don't have one size we actually have
a particle size distribution
in this case uh if you would like to
describe
this we and with one number right
um typically we use d50
uh this is the medium value that is the
half of the population is here half of
the population is here
um but of course for the same
d50 we can have different distributions
right it could be narrower
it can be much wider so
to have an idea about the span of the
distribution
we can use d10 and d90 values so
10 percent of the population is below
this value
90 percent of the populations below this
value
um another important thing here is the y
axis
so we have we can just count the numbers
of particles
we can measure the surface area we can
measure the volume typically in laser
diffraction particle size analysis
we use the volume basis so
in the stock as well i'll use d50 based
on
volume okay
so now we can talk about how
actually we can measure particle size
using light what is the fundamental
principle so when light
scatters from a particle the intensity
and the angle depends on the dimension
principle simply lets us build a
particle size analyzer
using light uh the underlying physics
theory is called
mia scattering theory this plot comes
from the paper
so here you see at different angles
the scatter intensity for three
different particle sizes
so a device using this principle should
do two things to measure particle size
right
first it has to be able to
measure the intensity and the angle
information
and then it has to transform this
information into particle size
distribution
there are certain assumptions for mia
scattering theory to work
these are that the particle should be
spherical
the the group should be homogeneous we
should know the refractive index of the
medium
around the particle and the particle
itself
and there is single scattering that is
the sket
particle um the light scatters only once
and it doesn't scatter from another
particle
right so it only scatters once as long
as
these assumptions are valid um this
theory works so let's actually look at
the commercial device
this comes from oribo's website
they have a schematic of the their
device
a laser diffraction particle size
analyzer
so it has two light sources for
different particle sizes
and the rest you see so the particles
are here
the rest measures the intensity at
different
angles right these are photo detectors
so they note
there are like 80 plus photo detectors
covering a wide range of
angles um now the researchers in this
paper the team asked the following
question
can we measure angle intensity
information with
just one sensor uh
you can really see the implications of
this right instead of
using 80 plus detectors can we use just
one
then it will be much smaller and much
cheaper
but it's not an easy task like how can
you capture this information angle and
intensity with just one sensor
so here's what they did
so most of the setup is very similar to
the commercial one
we have the particles here they flow
through the flow cell
so the particles are inside water
in this case they flow here there is a
collimated light beam
that hits the particle light scatters
so everything up to now is just
traditional
like scattering and then there is this
this filter here the sensor is behind
the filter
the there's just one sensor so the
novelty actually
comes from the filter let's see what
this filter does
here you see quickly from my side so um
just make sure that i'm on the same page
as you sure
so um so when you say measuring
particles how big are these particles
and what makes it so difficult to
measure these things well uh
it could be from nanometers to
millimeters
so you cannot just use a ruler
right there are many different ways to
measure particles
but um
light i mean using light the advantage
is
it's fast there are methods like for
example you can use a microscope
really to just take a picture
and measure them but it's not as
fast so this is really relevant
for industrial applications as i
mentioned these applications
so you're producing particles let's say
and you want to characterize them fast
right so this gives you a really fast
option to see the range
in this particular paper we focused the
size
i will mention but still it's from 10
microns to
125 microns but this this
could be much wider if you want right
is that answering yeah thank you
question thanks
keep going so
uh this is the filter an actual
photograph
so we see that there are holes in the
cylinders
the cylinder length is on the order of
centimeters
and the diameter of these holes
are on the order of hundreds of microns
so the aspect ratio is quite high here
you see that an
actual image falling onto the sensor
here
and now let's see how this captures this
angle and intensity information right so
now we know
what it looks like but let's see how it
works
so a light with a scattering
angle of 0 can just pass freely
from all these holes right but then
if it's scattered with an angle
other than zero it should be lower than
this
angle for it to pass right this is the
cut-off angle
so if if the scattering angle is less
than this angle
the light will pass say it's like this
you will be able to pass if it's larger
than this
angle it will hit the wall right so
this is called the cutoff angle of the
hole within this there are many holes
you see
so for each of them depending on the
diameter the cut-off angles are
different so so far so good right why do
we need
machine learning we can capture the
angle intensity information
as i explained we need to do two things
for this device to work
uh but i only explained the first part
right we have
we capture the information angle and
intensity
but now we need to transform this
information into particle size
distribution
how do we do that so in a sense we have
this picture
now we need the particle size
information
so the mia scattering theory as i
explained
it is based on the single scattering
approximation this
comes from the paper but for this setup
for this
filter for this sensor we had
multiple scattering so the assumption
fails
that is since the concentration of the
particles are high
the light scatter once and then once
more
and then maybe three four times e right
so this is why we need
to machine learning to correct this and
to
get um the particle size information
from this image so now
i can explain the machine learning model
development
so this is our setup we have this image
and from this image we'll input this to
a machine learning model
and you would like to output a particle
size prediction
specifically d50 based on worry
an important question here was are we
going to use
concentration here as
input so if we use it
we assume that our model will person
perform much better but from a practical
point of view
it should work without concentration as
input because
we don't always know the concentration
here right
so we said okay let's do both and
compare so you'll see
both models uh
another discussion was to how to correct
for the background
lightning conditions so we took a
reference image with water only
so without the particles the rest is the
same so we use this to correct for the
background
so in a sense we put this image as well
now an important question here is how do
we evaluate the model performance
so the iso standard says for such a
device
uh if you're measuring spherical
particles
your error should be less than 2.5
percent
for your d50 should be less than 2.5
percent
so this will be our benchmark this is an
important number
to keep in mind uh
so our metric for this case is
mean absolute percentage error
we use this metric so that we can
compare with
our benchmark okay
so let's see the data set
you can imagine that for such a problem
we need
many images right at different particle
sizes
and concentrations
so this is how our data set looked like
we measured
as i explained particle sizes
from 10 microns to 120
we measured these particles at different
concentrations right
not just 1 and 10 but in between many
concentrations
here as well and per
particle size and per concentration we
took five
images so this is how the data set looks
like
in total we had around 450 images
this is not much for machine learning as
you might know
but still a good starting point
these labels here you see are obtained
by a commercial device laser defector
particle size analyzer
now let's look at the pipelines right
how does this work
first i extracted
so i find the filter holes in scikit
learn you can use the blob finders to
find these holes in your images so this
is what i used
uh with that you can actually calculate
the intensity right it's just the pixel
values
and then the areas the areas of those
it's
using the radius of the
holes found then as i explained
i used the water image only waters
to convert these values into percentages
finally another future to add is with
concentration
so we have 46 here and 47 futures
as input right then
the random forest motor the particle
size the d50 value
the second pipeline is almost exactly
the same only difference is this is
without the concentration
so as you can imagine for this data set
i split into
train and test so let's see the test
results
okay um the percentage error
here with concentration is 2.5 percent
and without concentration it's five
percent
so here we are almost there uh for the
iso standard
uh here we are out of spec
let me explain what this graph is right
um
so this is the predictions
and these are the labels so here imagine
that we have
for each label for each particle size
we made multiple predictions right we
have many images
per label so for one
prediction you can read the predicted
value here
on the y-axis and the label here
but to show it much better as a summary
i use the mean of these predictions so
this is the mean
and this is the entire decile range that
is the middle 80 percent
so i did this for all the particle sizes
here even you can notice actually that
almost all of this error is coming from
two particles the rest
looks fine and here as well it's coming
from this
a little bit of this and this one so
this is something to note
i'll explain this later another thing we
wanted to do
is how uh predictions behave
with respect to concentration right
this these plots alone doesn't give you
that information
so this is what we did we plotted our
predictions these dots
with respect to concentration so this is
the concentration axis
these are the particle sizes so
the label in a sense is the straight
line
when you change the concentration your
predictions should
stay the same and we can see that even
for the model without concentration as
input
it's quite horizontal for almost all
except these two right these two
particles
we see some fluctuation around the
correct
value okay so
this is like an introduction to the
pipeline right
but let's move on sorry
just maybe just one question that came
through um
why did you use a random forest so i
think you you said you used random
forest
why did you choose that and did you
explore other
other options so actually
from kaggle i know that uh
for tabular data for structured data
uh random forest variants is al
almost always is the winning algorithm
right there is gradient boosting
etc but they're all a family of
algorithms
so this was the main reason i picked so
it's not really
i tried many algorithms i did a model
selection no it's just that
i would i expected that this would
work then i actually tried a couple of
other models and didn't see
a big improvement right so i stuck with
it
that's the reason so for images i go
with resnet
for structured data i go with random
forests
that's the reason thank you cool
so now we can discuss a little bit of
the details
so is this real this is the most
important question in machine learning
if you see a good performance from your
model whatever it is
the question is are you fitting the
signal
or are you fitting the noise how do you
know
right because you can get high
performance
by fitting the noise as well
so we did many tests uh i will explain
two of them
to show that we are not fitting the
noise hopefully
so if you look at this setup one thing
you might notice that
we take five images back to back
so one problem might be if you take
these images too fast
maybe they're not really independent
from each other right so when you
do a train test split actually there is
a leakage between your train and test
sets
so you get high performance just because
these images are too similar to each
other
so how do we test for that so i
discussed this with the
phd student the first author chubaya
she said she used tens of seconds
between the images
so that seems good enough right the
particles are flowing
so you expect in 10 seconds
significant change of the distribution
but still we wanted to test it
so in this image can i
quickly ask another question from
charlene's which might be good to
answer already so uh
yeah carlos asking why did you use this
loss function exactly
which lost function i think the
so you didn't specify if right but the
one from the random forest that you used
first of all so for random forest i
didn't specify exactly
it works so loss function
is mostly used for parametric models
random forest is a non-parametric model
in this case
i use gini coefficient to
so maybe i need to explain how random
forest works
to give answers in detail but basically
you split the data sets
using trees right this is how random
forests work
and the trees these branches split the
data
using the genie impurity concept
so it's not really a loss function
it's you cannot call it a loss function
but this is how
uh to do the splits basically
yeah so what i actually think but
is maybe carlo means mappy
as a evaluation uh metric okay why
mapping
simply because to match so
loss function and metric are different
things right
uh even for a parametric model loss
function is what you optimize
that is what you try to minimize but the
metric
can be something different right you can
use
mean square error as a loss function but
accuracy
is a metric because accuracy makes sense
to humans when i if i give you a loss
function number like 0.5
it doesn't mean anything is it good or
bad but if i tell you
[Music]
90 accuracy then it makes sense right so
to
to we used the mean absolute percentage
errors
because then we can't compare this to
the iso standard
it makes sense that's the reason
and i think also if you didn't use the
percentage error then you get strange
results
um given that some particles are smaller
than others right
so you care more about the percentage
error than actually
just normal actual zero exactly right
sure okay so
let me let me discuss this again
are we fitting the noise right this is
the question
so notice there is a big hole
what is this um
so this is actually the light scattering
profile
right before the filter right so here
the light scatters from the particles
and then
enters the filter right so this
gives me the intensity right before
the filter so i decided to move these
holes
here so if i'm fitting the noise
then i should be able to make
predictions
using this fall as well
so the results should be like this if
i'm fitting the noise the accuracy
should be high right my error should be
low
if i'm not fitting the noise if i'm
fitting the signal if i'm doing things
correctly
then i should see a high error for this
case
uh and luckily we got this
the error was quite high so that means
the effect we are seeing
is actually coming from the filter
itself right
for the same images with the light
intensity
in sense intensity here i couldn't get
good predictions so it's actually the
filter
giving me the good results
but this is not still enough we wanted
to do another test
that is okay let's do another experiment
collect new data so this is always very
important right doing an external test
okay you collect a data set you split it
into two
you have a test set but always there
could be a leakage so
we wanted to do okay for just two
particle sizes
let's repeat the experiment and see
if we can measure and we can actually
as you can see our error was 1.7 percent
so notice here we also did something
different
during the data set collection it was
all like
uh okay we pick a particle size we take
measurements and then we clean the flow
cell
in this case it was more close to the
industrial application that is we send
in the particles
of this size and without cleaning or
changing the setup
we sand in the second particles so in
this case still we were able to
measure the particle size
now another question is that you might
ask
you that i was talking about particle
size distribution
but i'm predicting the 50 what about
the span the the 10 right so we also
tried that and
we were able to predict the 10 and the
90 as well so this is a completely
different model right
a model a random forest model that can
output three
values and we were able to predict more
or less
uh these values as well i want to
note one thing here that we didn't
emphasize
this result this result is inside the
paper but we didn't emphasize this
as much because to be able to sure
i mean if you want to be sure that
you're correctly predicting the 10 and
the 90
again you need the following you need
different particle size distributions
at the same d50 but different
d10 and d90 values so that you're sure
you're exactly predicting d10 and d90
not like you are memorizing the
difference between the 50 and 10s and
just predicting this
and calculating b10 and d90 from d50
right we didn't have that kind of
particles it's
theoretically less it's really nice but
in practice you cannot really control i
want this d50
same and this is the 10 is 1990
so we didn't have that and
finally an important point
i mentioned that these look like
uh giving much higher errors than these
right these particles
so we realized that direction these are
actually
uh are from different producers right
these particles are produced
from producer a and these are coming
from producer b
so maybe there's something to be
concerned about
and we'll rubaia took these pictures
you can see non-spherical particles here
right
so when we remove these non-spherical
particles
our error actually reduces quite much
right below one percent and within
the spec actually within the iso
standards
sure again from scott he's a
fellow chemist and he's curious about
what type of particles these exactly are
well we did quite a bit of experiments i
need to check this is written in the
paper
i think they are polystyrene beads
but uh we need to check what materials
so maybe for the less less chemist
people on the line is this
organic or inorganic and mixed
and how small did you go
uh i really don't remember the
properties in terms of the materials
i think they are polystyrene but i'm not
sure right we need to check the paper
uh small you mean the particle size
yes if you went below submicron scale
we have actually
now actually so this paper is one year
old
uh we are working on it still we are
improving
and we are working on smaller uh
particles as well
but it's not included in the paper
but the thing is the particle size here
is
the range we have is fixed by the filter
the filter its length and the diameter
of the hose
defines what particle size
range you can measure so with this
specific
filter we cannot go below or above
so we changed the setup a little
so that we can go below this range as
well
but that's a future work we did
right see interesting and then i had
another question
um it's a back a couple of slides with
you so it was interesting that you
tested on
the holes outside the holes if i can
explain it like that
but it does look like there's still a
little bit of a trend right
yes so what's the explanation for still
seeing a little bit of a trend well
actually by eye if you look at the
images
just here you can see this because
of course the intensity before the
filter
you can see it change when you change
the particle size when you say change
the concentration
so there is some signal with i you can
at least say okay this particle size
is quite higher than that particle size
right maybe then you cannot predict
exactly
what the particle size is but you can
predict the trend
just by looking at the
intensity here so basically if there's
bigger particles inside the fluid then
the light is scattering
so even if you're not looking at the
holes
there's still more light lost if there
are particles are
bigger so the part when the part when we
have larger particles
light scatters less so the relationship
is this
so light hits the particle so if it's
large
the angle is low if it's small the angle
is high
so this is the basic relationship
uh and depending also on the
concentration you can
really see the change when you just move
from image to image
fast you can see the change so as a
human we can make predictions without
any calculation just by looking at the
images
we can learn the relationships but our
accuracy will be low this is what
we are seeing basically
so i was here actually um
this is this is it um
about the details and if you don't have
any questions
i'll move on to the take-home messages
okay sure go ahead
so here i'll discuss the physics driven
model to data
and then i'll compare applied machine
learning to
machine learning research this comes
from a blog post
i've written you can read it here in
detail
but to be able to make this comparison
first we need to understand models right
i really like the saying all models are
wrong but some are useful
understanding this is fundamental
so models are a simplification of
reality
right it's a simplification at the cost
of accuracy
one model is not better than the others
inherently you cannot say such a thing
sphere is better than flat earth
it depends on the application so if you
are going to the supermarket
this model is not better than flat earth
right
for our day-to-day activities we are
actually
considering the earth to be flat but
of course for a much complex
project like launching a satellite you
should
be as accurate as it is right then you
can afford the complexity
so this is very important to understand
and
in this case for the particle size
analysis this is what we had
this is the spec we had
the mesquite model it was not accurate
enough
due to multiple scattering
in the literature there are actually
models that correct for multiple
scattering but the problem is
they are too complex like iterative
models that needs to do
fitting so it takes time really to
fit these models and it's not really
suitable for an
online industrial application right the
particles are flowing
you want to monitor the particle size
almost real time
so with machine learning we were able to
do this right
move into spec this was the
advantage of machine learning but it
doesn't mean it's like machine learning
is always advantageous
with respect to physics of course not
noticed that the signal was in the data
thanks to the physics knowledge right
the filter design
was guided by mia theory so
without that knowledge without that
design machine learning
cannot work just by looking at the
scattered intensity without the filters
the other thing is causation versus
correlation with
its current form we can only discover
correlations with machine learning
physics is the way that provides the
causation
that helps us explain things
then another problem with machine
learning is generalization right okay
for this setup for these particles it
works
but if one if you want to generalize to
a different lab
different particles then we need data
from those situations right
so generalization power of physics
is much better
so the best thing is actually to combine
them
in a sense in this project we combine
them we
implicitly guided our model in a sense
using physics knowledge but you can also
explicitly do that
there is something called physics guided
neural networks
in this case what they are doing was
uh into the loss function
they put a physical law so
they punish physically inconsistent
results right explicitly
forcing the neural network to learn
physically consistent
results i also wrote about these
in the blog post explained how they work
so you can read if you're interested
and the other message here is
machine learning research if you're
familiar with it
assumes fixed benchmark data sets and
focuses on architecture and optimization
but applied machine learning
is about data collection and domain
knowledge so
in this talk even in this talk you saw
that i
didn't talk much about the architecture
how i trained the hyper parameters i
focus
mostly on the data data collection
explanation
if you do this if you do that right
[Music]
and even for machine learning research i
think this is very important because
for popular data sets like imagenet this
is the most popular
benchmark data set it has its own
problems it
has its biases so if you are interested
you can
read this paper here object net to see
the problems with imagenet so i think
also for research
the data sets are important
with that i conclude my talk i hope you
enjoyed it
and now we can have some questions thank
you